sekito has no character customization it
has no stat leveling no multiplayer and
apparently no weapons or armor to
collect that's heavy but I'm sure the
gameplay we've lost will give way to
something more useful I think that's
what
sekito is about in more ways than one
and you'll learn to appreciate its worth
I'll give you an example think about
leveling up in a Souls game investing
souls in the stats of your character
it's this hugely important system for an
RPG but it is also something that can
inhibit freedom and take Dark Souls 1
you have this fantastically into woven
tangled world design that allows you to
progress in random directions to an
extent but many stages and bosses are
impossible or tedious for a low-level
character and if you have this open
world why should you be restricted in
where you're allowed to go that's
something that breath of the wild for
example did amazingly and here's the big
news sekito is confirmed to be more open
world with the interwove entangled level
design of the original Dark Souls and
that's huge in addition to this by sort
of stripping away the leveling grind as
well it's going to be a lot easier for
them to truly open up the world because
the only barrier to progression in a
game like this are your strengths and
weaknesses as a player their philosophy
is going to be let players explore the
world and my point is this could be
better than what we've lost so I hope
this one example can sort of help
convince you that losing one mechanic
can manifest itself is a good thing in
many other areas and really I'm just
glad we get to celebrate this return to
an inter woven tangled map design I feel
like Dark Souls set an industry-standard
with its map design and then kind of
abandoned it
in subsequent titles so I really hope we
see a return to form here and honestly
imagine how much more we could do now
that we have a jump button see how high
the player is jumping here that's it
that's the jump in the e3 demo
apparently almost everything could be
hurdled and it seems like we're going to
even be able to go through some walls
hidden passages that are usable only by
the shinobi and all of this all of this
crazy verticality and exploration
techniques is permissible because for
the first time our character is taking
on asset class we are a shinobi not a
spell casting mage not a plate clad tank
we are a katana wielding shinobi always
so as a result Sakura will revolve
around our character like never before
because we're actually playing a set
protagonist here and I get it the first
instinct is kind of to freak out for
example you might worry that the story
is going to be linear and shallow but
don't worry because on the contrary
miyazaki has stressed that nothing has
changed in their stance to storytelling
from the previous games so the game will
still have a deep complex world it's not
like I was freaking out or anything but
unfortunately having a set protagonist
does have some implications for
character customization for example no
longer will we be able to make these
hideous abominations in the character
creator nor will we be able to find
weapons or armor to upgrade our
character with and it's gonna be a bit
harder to roleplay but you know what
they haven't completely ruled out
customization so I wonder if you guys
have any ideas do you think they'll go
down the skin's route neo is our closest
parallel it's this souls like game with
a male protagonist that can have his
entire appearance changed from smaller
tweaks to like his hairstyle and his
beard to entire skins that can have you
playing as a female or a different
legendary character and I think having
something like this in sekito is going
to be important especially if they're on
locked in really interesting ways like
completing a unique or difficult
achievement or something like that
because I'd certainly rather complete
interesting gameplay challenges then
unlock them by spending money in a skins
shop for example but can't rule that out
at the very least it does seem like
we'll be able to customise our character
a bit through the way we play for
instance which shinobi prosthetic we'll
decide to take into battle
we'll definitely play a big part and
we're told that there's supposed to be a
sort of upgrade system for them that
requires currency and having a wider
range of these will allow us to have
more unique ways of approaching combat
and speaking of prosthetics there's also
been a shrew aching arm that has been
confirmed and I wouldn't be surprised if
there were more ranged assassination
options like throwing organs
considering all the height advantages
we're going to have on our enemies and
taking someone out from afar in a
stealthy manner sounds like it's right
up our alley so getting into combat this
brings us to swordplay in the last video
based on how much we saw in the trailer
we speculated that swordplay was going
to be way more important and we were
right Miyazaki described the combat as a
clashing of swords and you're not gonna
be dashing around your enemies like you
do in a souls game and this is because
of the new posture system which is at
the core of swordplay
it's a meter which replaces stamina
apparently and revolves around how well
you can time the blocking of an attack
so when you block an enemy attack and
press block too early you'll lose a
little bit of posture but if you
perfectly time your block almost as if
it was a parry then your opponent will
lose their posture instead and if you
can deplete their posture enough you'll
knock them off-balance opening them up
to a critical strike which finishes your
opponent off in a spectacular show of
gore and blood so it's a fascinating
system because having no stamina really
incentivizes you to attack right but
remember your opponent can lower your
posture as well with a welt
and block so you will get punished for
lazy predictable attacks it reminds me a
lot of a piranha and its combat system
where you have to analyze your
opponent's sword play style exploiting
their weaknesses while also protecting
your own and of course you have to keep
your health in mind as well
healing items will only carry you so far
so the question is going to become how
willing are you to risk your own health
for that perfectly timed block that
could knock your opponent off balance
and end the fight right there all I can
say is I've never been this high up it's
to test out a demo build and try this
for myself because it just sounds so
unique and I know a lot of you are
worried about stale movesets
but it's not all bad Miyazaki states
that they intend to implement a number
of sword styles that you can learn in
the form of skills allowing you to
switch up the way that you use the
katana also there's a second katana on
the dudes back in the cover art and I
seriously doubt we're not going to be
dual wielding that at some point and
that's not all we speculated about
abilities in the last video and they've
been confirmed as well so according to
variety calm there are also powerful
abilities that can imbue your sword with
fire one particularly useful skill lets
you assassinate enemies and then turn
their blood into a choking smoke so I
think this is saying we can repurpose
the blood of those we kill and turn them
into environmental effects that is cool
another such skill was the ability to
come back to life after death so
continuing with that smoke theme this
ability is apparently cold blood smoke
allowing you to spring back to life with
the press of a button
however this mechanic is still in the
process of being fine-tuned
but according to Miyazaki revives are
currently guaranteed once with
additional revives requiring additional
resources and from the interviews you
get this sense that they're very aware
that we might think this makes the game
easy but rest assured they actually
intends to make this game even more
difficult than the previous entries with
no difficulty slider so shadows die
twice but
casuals will die more than twice and the
amazing thing about the revived mechanic
is how fluidly it matches the stealth
aspect of the game because it's such a
natural way of establishing a state of D
agro where enemies have forgotten about
you leaving you in a position where you
can either walk away and take your
losses or double down and to reinitiate
the fight if you're thirsting for
revenge miyazaki mentions that when you
meet an enemy in this game you won't be
immediately plunged into battle the
levels are designed to let you observe
enemies split them up or take them out
quietly one by one and apparently get
this you can even listen in on enemies
if you're close enough I mean their
mouths won't move it's from software but
apparently their conversations will give
you hints about their strengths and
weaknesses but forget gameplay for a
second are you guys thinking what I'm
thinking
can you imagine all the fantastic law
that we might be able to overhear that
would be such a cool method of
discovering it right oh this is
fantastic it suits Souls so well and
stealth makes it into boss fights as
well at e3 cat-and-mouse boss fights
were described against incomprehensibly
large monsters where one has to use
stealth in the fight itself to gain an
advantage and you all remember the
dragon god from demon souls don't you
it's like the only example of stealth
gameplay in souls I think and it's not a
great fight but imagine how to hem
exciting this could be with actual
stealth mechanics honestly I've never
been more excited for boss fights
because in addition to stealth boss
fights imagine how well the grappling
hook and jump button could work in them
because in seoul's large monsters are
often a really big chore to fight
against right they take up too much
screen real estate and we often only
ever see their feet it's not good but in
cicchitto you have the opportunity to
get some distance from a boss and fit
them in your camera
because an entire new dimension has
opened up above us imagine a shadow of
the colossus style boss that has to be
ascended to be defeated or what about
fighting another shinobi that has you
jumping and freerunning all over the
place they could even implement chase
sequences where you have to free run
across rooftops there's just my mind is
going wild with all the opportunities
they have here and I hope they live up
to it the only two bosses that we've
seen so far though are the giant snake
which apparently has to be stealth
passed in the canyon and this the
corrupted monk an 11 foot tall woman
wielding a naginata blade which was
something that was commonly wielded by
women of the samurai class as it allowed
them to keep men at a distance where
advantages in height weight and
upper-body strength would matter a lot
less the corrupted monk allegedly fights
with illusion cloning herself and coming
at you in this arena that is billowing
with cherry blossom petals oh but you
know what kind of ruins boss fights
sometimes having three people wail on
them in co-op it is true but the
experience is often a little bit lesser
for those who make every single boss a
breeze by summoning others I mean if
Edward can get through Dark Souls then
maybe there's something wrong here
so coming as a surprise to many sekito
will feature no multiplayer according to
your hero from software they wanted to
focus on the single-player experience
without any of the limitations that come
with designing game meant as multiplayer
so personally for me this is pretty
devastating
I don't feature it much on the channel
but I love PvP and multiplayer in my
games but for the sake of argument I
will admit that there are advantages to
designing without it for example can you
imagine how difficult it would be to
place fog gates in a world that is
really open likes Aikido especially open
the vertical level and also enemies
won't have to be designed to target
multiple players and hopefully the
resources that they're saving from
balancing everything in a PvP sense can
be fully invested elsewhere however I
remain to be convinced that connections
to other worlds won't exist at all in
some capacity I mean not having a blood
stain or a messaging mechanic would be
pretty rough and Activision is pretty
synonymous with multiplayer titles it's
good however to see that both companies
seem to have really healthy boundaries
amazake is stressing that all the
decisions after the title screen still
belong to them and that Activision
actually has a lot of data and internal
testing that has been invaluable to them
as a smaller studio especially when it
comes to new players not quitting in the
first 10 minutes there are some really
good interviews with Robert konkey of
Activision and Yasuhiro katay Oh from
software in the description so even
though sekito has less Souls elements
than expected this is good for from
because people who actually care about
from software as a studio know that they
need to experiment with new things and
while we all love Souls even I don't
want them to do it forever and I rely on
it they'll go creatively bankrupt if
they do and there are a lot of studios
that do that and it's never a good thing
in the end so please if you see anyone
online or in the comments expressing
absolute despair about this game
challenge them on their way of thinking
I have a lot of faith that you guys will
be able to do that tell them to stay
calm and subscribe / do on patreon throw
that in there somewhere and if all else
fails remind them that there will always
be other games on the horizon many
prominent Lakers are actually stating
that sekito wasn't even the souls like
game that they were anticipating being
announced and that there is another more
Souls like game coming soon it's just
rumors but we'll likely see more
gameplay of sekito at Gamescom showing
the demo that journalists got to play
behind closed doors at e3 until then we
still have to talk about the story of
this game the tale of a lonely shinobi
lost his young master so for that I'll
see you next time
you